how do you know your team's strong
enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bull and don't wave the red cape
i just want to first say congratulations
on the film i've had a chance to watch
it
i think people are going to be very
excited to see what you've delivered
this time
you've been with this project for so
long in so many different ways
and with these characters for even
longer and i'm just wondering
what was the pens down moment where you
were like
okay i this is it this is this is the
finished product
and and how did you feel in that moment
you mean just now on finishing it yeah
it was very you know we all um we all
had a glass of wine and toasted each
other uh the whole group
debbie and i and my visual effects team
and my
editorial team and we all just i called
a bunch of like you know my friends
who've worked on it and
we all just kind of had this cathartic
moment where we said okay
it's done and uh it was funny because it
was kind of a schedule
if the schedule made it happen thank god
if you know if the pandemic or if this
movie was
due to release another month or two we'd
still be working on i'm sure
so uh yeah we kind of got i mean thank
god you know because
it put us up against the clock and so it
was it was cool it was
it was a nice bit of stuff so you
attempted to still go keep going and
tingling
i don't think we'd ever would have
stopped if we
that's awesome well i want to take you
back to another moment and that was the
time
i believe it was you got the call from
toby emerick and they said it's a go
we're
we're going to do this can you talk a
little bit about that call and and what
the feeling was to know that it was
finally going to happen
there was an initial call that said you
know do you want to release the movie
um right off your laptop just as it is
i'm like yeah i don't think i want to do
that that's not really
it doesn't really seem like it's going
to be good for anybody and then um
and then i said hey let me just come
into the studio and tell you what i
would do
and i went in and i just told them about
the scope and scale and what i thought i
could achieve and all that
then they all came over to the house and
watched the movie that i had
on my down at my theater and uh they
were like okay let's do it
and i think that that moment um you know
where i really believed it was happening
you know that was a moment that um
i think we all felt
well first of all it was a huge
undertaking that we knew we had to
accommodate
it was a moment of dread and a moment of
like
you know adulation because we but we had
definitely reached a kind of a cathartic
tipping point where we felt like there
could healing could start
for all of us awesome and scope and
scale
it's it's it's huge um what was it like
to paint on this
this size of canvas and this length to
give the room to tell
these stories as fully as you wanted to
um
and sort of i don't know about complete
artistic freedom but to really stretch
that muscle
i mean not to say we didn't have any
oversight we had the budget we had these
other things constraints have covered
you know there's a lot of things that
did kind of keep us in the box thank god
but you know as far as just me doing
what i thought was
cool it's 100 that this is the cut that
i completed in january
of 2017. so um
you know give or take a little bit of
squishing but essentially that's it so
to come back to it and sort of
re-experience it
was quite an also quite a quite a
sort of reunion if you will and to see
how it was gonna
with all the visual facts and the design
and everything
kind of really be realized and you've
said that this film
really cyborg is the heart of the movie
and you absolutely get that sense
watching it
to the extent that you know the title
lands on this beautiful shot
of rey um in the film and you really
centered it and you get
so much of this beautiful story about
this man
why was it important for you to really
center rey's character victor in
in your story well chris ontario and i
we had long conversations about when we
were getting ready to make
first of all write the script for
justice league but then you know make
the film
but when we were banging out the story
we felt like
this character cyborg as a character was
really the one we wanted to focus on
we felt like he's an incredible
character in the dc universe
he's an important character in the dc
universe and he just really needed
his story told in a way that was
also in context of these other gods
you know that that established him
in that pantheon you know and that was
really
um a thing we just we we really
focused on from the beginning and then
it's really fun to see it
realized because it really ray does an
incredible job
and have you spoken to ray and the
others
having now i assume some of them have
seen the film and in its complete form
and
and what's the what's the reaction like
to see to see the decision
ray hasn't seen it yet he's seen it
hopefully in the next couple days um
uh but um yeah they've been really
supportive and incredibly enthusiastic
about
film and about you know me being able to
get it
get it finished so you know we wouldn't
be here without the fans and obviously
the huge campaign um that sort of
brought us to this point
and there were so many you know so many
amazing stories of what happened during
that campaign and i'm wondering
is there a moment in interaction um i
don't know if it's the retweets or it's
the billboard or what it is that really
stands out to you as like
the thing that you'll you'll take with
you from this this release the snyder
cup campaign
yeah so many memories really to be
honest like the idea that
i remember when we there was the
comic-con bus stops
that kind of started it and then there
was that big gigantic billboard in times
square
and i think that um made me
really start to go wow i don't know what
these guys are up to but this is
legitimate caring and
uh you know whether it be the airplanes
flying around warner brothers towing
banners or the million fruit baskets
delivered to ann sarnoff when she became
president
of the foreigners i really think in the
end
it's just how supportive they've been of
afsp and suicide prevention and mental
health awareness
like really that is the jewel in the
crown of what they've accomplished and
for me
it's better than any movie is this
persistent campaign
that these guys have mounted you know in
regard to
suicide prevention and mental health
awareness that's really it i mean
they've saved lives with their campaign
and
that's the bottom line and i can't you
know it's fun to make a movie but that's
really cool stuff
yeah and i think i mean that probably
bleeds into what i
what i assume you might say about the
next question but a lot of the discourse
around
fandom does recently at least tends to
focus on you know quote-unquote toxic or
negative fandom and
i'm i'm talking to you from rotten
tomatoes so we are part of the story in
some ways
uh you know they they don't like the
scores on some of the films etc
but for those who only focus on the
negative side of fandom
what do you want people to know about
fans of dc and fans of yours and
and what they've been doing um
listen i think the fans you can't throw
a blanket over the entire thing because
everyone's
this is a bunch of individuals these
people aren't professionals they're not
paid
to do anything they're just fans of the
movies
and they want you know in my case they
just want the movie out there that
i that i had designed and created
originally
and then along the way they got involved
in my cause and
and in for whatever reason they had some
sort of empathy
or whether they had an experience
themselves uh
and it's a combination of those things
that i think has
has made the fans like this community
that i interact with but they are
now um and i think that
you know there are look there are there
occasions
of of fandom where it gets out of
control absolutely we all know that
but the reality is is that you know
these fans use their voices to change
the course of a giant
corporation and to basically get a movie
release
that you know i always say like look the
real miracle is that
like someone would say like oh are you
ever going to make a sequel i'm like
well there's no plan
and warner brothers really has no
interest in making sequel with me
but is it more likely that a sequel to
this movie would have been made
than what happened and the answer that
is yes
and so you know it just it just speaks
to their their actual power
and and i'm and i'm proud to be you know
associated with them
um one of the scenes that's going to
really impress fans i think
is is one to one at the end towards the
end i don't know are we allowed to talk
about this
in in context at this point or i don't
know dummy
uh you brought you bring together two
iconic characters you've obviously
dropped the hints of what's happening as
a fan and as someone who's worked on
this
for a long time what was it like to to
put them together and
and write that script and shoot
something new
for this film the scene was important to
me because i felt like
if this is the last gasp of uh
you know zack snyder's tc universe which
is more than a gasp
it's a it's a it's a booming shout out
the last movie shout then
uh i really wanted to like say you know
i have a little bit of unfinished
business and that is to bring these two
characters together
and also i'm a fan of
and very excited by the nightmare post
dark side world and uh love it and
have always loved the concept and was
working my way there as best i could
um with these movies um and so it's fun
to
all it's always fun to sort of dabble in
that i want to talk to you about
directors cuts in general
and how important you feel it is for
directors in your position to be able to
you know get their vision out into the
world
you've had a few instances where you've
been able to give us alternative cuts
and things and there are rumors of other
cuts of dc movies and other movies
flying around and i'm wondering
for you why is it important that someone
in your position
who has a fandom who's really interested
in your vision get to see that
as intended i've made direct cuts of
almost every movie i've ever made except
for i think guardians go
and mana steel and i would argue that
the sucker punch
director's got isn't really the full
movie like
that's the one movie i would say oh yeah
there's a there's a cut of that movie
that no one's ever seen
i i prefer the bbs ultimate edition
which is the director's guide
because i just feel like it's less
encumbered by the studio and by the
notes
and just by the constraints of what they
think a movie has to be in its length
and people can't
nobody wants to see a three-hour movie
i'm not i don't agree with that 100
but anyway so as far as other filmmakers
go
and their kind of experience with
directors cuts
i i can't say exactly it's personal to
me you know this
it's a way i've kind of justified the
you know
making changes to the movies that i've
worked on is knowing that i could always
just release the director's cut and at
least feel like okay well
there's the real movie you know um so
i'm fine
and i understand the balance between art
and commerce
and sort of that you know there's there
is a you do have to strike a balance
sometimes
the theatrical cut of watchmen is based
entirely on
maximum running length of film in imax
the film could be no longer than
two hours and 20 minutes or it would
have fallen off the spool and so that's
where you see
the sort of two things coming together
and and you have to accept that
if you want the movie that way and i did
my point is only that
it is a business and so you know what
will the market bear
is a real is a real question is it my
hope that
this movement might generate a little
bit more
um power for some directors that are in
like a
situation where like you know they're
not sure if they're going to get their
movie completed
that'd be great but um this is a very
sort of particular situation i think
in that is it very the breadcrumbs lead
directly to us a narrative that the fans
were able to put together
and turn into a rallying pride it was a
perfect storm of all those things
and you know and their charities and
their caught and the cause
and the whole thing kind of has a
blended reality that i think would be
hard to duplicate and
would i hope that you know someone
benefits from this absolutely great
[Music]
[Applause]
you said the age of heroes would never
come again
[Music]
it will it has to
you